bom a obrigado a todos pela presença é
como todo o time apresentou meu nome é
felipe e eu trabalho no cemec centro de
biologia molecular engenharia genética
sob orientação da doutora carlin e hoje
eu vim falar pra vocês um pouco do meu
trabalho é basicamente uma coisa que a
gente está sempre vindo na mídia hoje é
a palavra genoma ao genoma humano isso o
genoma humano aquilo mas o que que é o
genoma ele nada mais é do que o conjunto
de informações que descreve quem nós
somos
então é basicamente falar porque a cor
do meu cabelo é de um jeito um do outro
porque meu olho de um jeito um do outro
todas essas informações estão contidas
no nosso genoma ele é como se fosse um
livro de instruções em que vai estar
falando exatamente quem e como você é
porém essa se livre ele precisa ser lido
e para isso existe uma outra linguagem
que é chamada dna que são moléculas que
são capazes de ler essa informação e
transmitir ela para o resto do organismo
e o estudo dessas linguagens começou há
muito tempo lá pelo ano de 1986 e ela
recebeu o nome de genômica que uma
tradução livre seria o estudo do genoma
inicialmente essa é esse campo ele não
era muito grande pra vocês terem uma
idéia quando ele foi pela primeira vez
publicado em 1986 ele tinha cerca de 10
mil sequências ou seja 10 mil
informações contidas naquele banco
hoje em dia esse número passou para mais
de 100 bilhões de sequências publicadas
é um número um o volume de informações
que é muito alto é muito grande ea nossa
capacidade de leitura por mais que a
gente gostaria não chega com não
consegue acompanhar esse volume e pra
isso que surgiu e outras ferramentas que
permitirão que a gente conseguisse
estudar melhor este campo e essas
ferramentas foram desenvolvidas através
da computação foram chamadas de
bioinformática que é basicamente a
junção da biologia com a computação e
por exemplo
há um pouco de como funciona esse campo
eu vou falar um pouco pra vocês o
trabalho que estou desenvolvendo como é
eu mencionei e nós trabalhamos com a
esclerose lateral amiotrófica uma doença
neurodegenerativa
ou seja ela ataca e mata as células
nervosas neurônios e essa morte ela
acaba causando a atrofia muscular que
pode levar inclusive à morte da pessoa
pô parada respiratória porque ela não
consegue mais controlar os músculos da
própria respiração
o grande problema é que a grande questão
em aberto dessa doença é que a gente não
entende muito bem os mecanismos que
levam à morte do neurônio então a gente
sabe que eles morrem mas o porque ainda
não está sendo muito bem compreendido e
qual que é como que a gente está
abordando esse problema que a gente está
querendo fazer de diferente
basicamente o que nós estamos fazendo é
coletando as informações do genoma a
gente quer entender o que está
acontecendo no livro de instruções das
pessoas ou dos animais que têm essa
doença e para isso nós estamos usando é
dados coletados de camundongos
nós temos dois conjuntos né que foi um
conjunto de animais normais em um
conjunto de animais que apresentam essa
doença que foram modificados pra
apresentar isso então nós coletamos o rn
a desses animais do cérebro desses
animais que é onde a doença se manifesta
e mandamos esses moléculas por um
seqüenciador que é basicamente um
tradutor no que que o nh ele tem uma
linguagem própria que a gente não
consegue entender é como se você
recebesse um manual escrito em chinês e
precisava se traduzir alguma coisa e é
mais ou menos isso aqui que a gente tem
de resultado essa essas três primeiras
linhas
é mais ou menos o que o nosso
seqüenciador está falando pra gente
vocês vêem que é uma coisa relativamente
complexo não é uma coisa que você
consegue entender facilmente e só para
vocês terem uma noção do volume de dados
que é gerado em cada sequenciamento
é eu peguei só as três primeiras linhas
para exemplificar aqui mas o primeiro
megabyte de informação que é gerado por
um seqüenciador equivale a 282 páginas
de word em areal 10
então só isso já é uma coisa muito
grande cada arquivo tem aproximadamente
5.700 bytes ou seja é 282 páginas vezes
5.700 e nós temos um volume que são 21
experimentos ou seja no final a gente
fosse pegar todas as seqüências de
colocar em forma de texto seria
equivalente a 33 milhões 755 mil e
quatrocentas páginas de texto
isso na mais de 28 mil edições de volume
único de o senhor dos anéis ou seja é
uma coisa muito grande em viável para um
ser humano conseguir ler tudo isso e
fazer uma análise em tempo relativamente
curto simplesmente não dá é muito
complicado e é aí que entra o computador
a partir da informática
basicamente o que nós estamos fazendo é
pegar toda essa pilha de informações que
a gente tem que é muito grande muito
volumosa estamos aplicando algoritmos
que vão processar essa informação e dá
pra gente de volta uma informação mais
digerida ou seja uma coisa que a gente
consiga olhar e entender e analisar o
que é o que a gente quer no final a
gente entender o que está acontecendo e
basicamente o que esses programas fazem
esses algoritmos fazem é pegar cada uma
daquelas linhas do sequenciador cada uma
das 33 milhões e montar um quebra cabeça
porque que ele vai fazer ele vai tentar
encaixar uma linha com a outra e ver
onde é que está tendo sobre posição e é
como se você tivesse fazendo isso você
tem várias linhas é que cada linha
eu coloquei representada por uma
caixinha embaixo ele vai tentar encaixar
como estivesse montando o quebra-cabeça
de 33 milhões de peças e o mais legal é
que você não consegue só montar um
quebra cabeça porque ele não vai só
montar uma imagem você consegue contar
e quando você conta quantas caixinhas
tem dentro de cada região você consegue
ver realmente quais são as peças
importantes daquele quebra cabeça
por exemplo aqui você tem muito mais
caixinhas muito mais linhas nas regiões
são as caixas que são as questões
realmente importantes que vão passar
instrução correta para o corpo
porém as regiões onde são as linhas são
regiões que não têm uma informação
importante às vezes muito menos não
servem pra nada então o corpo não
precisa delas então vocês vêem que não
existe muita leitura nessa parte
porém a nossa ideia nossa hipótese é que
na doença da esclerose lateral essas
informações não estão sendo passadas de
forma correta e o que você teria seria
uma situação mais ou menos assim naquela
primeira linha onde não era pra ver tem
nenhuma leitura agora você tem várias
caixinhas que estão sendo é posicionada
salientam é como se aquela parte do
quebra cabeça que não era pra tá ali
umas peças peças extras não serão
inclusas e essa informação passa a ser
perfeito o asa e aí você tem um neurônio
que antes era super saudável e bonito e
agora ele está morrendo
isso porque a informação que ele deveria
estar recebendo não está certa e o que
nós conseguimos encontrar
foi justamente isso aqui na parte da
direita vocês conseguem observar que nós
encontramos cinco alvos que foram cinco
genes que estão com informação
defeituosa e à caixa a bolinha
quanto maior a bolinha maior é a taxa de
incidência desse erro ou seja aquele
primeiro só pra vocês tenham uma ideia
ele tem uma taxa de 12 vezes maior do
que no controle ou seja aquela
informação está sendo passado errada
muitas vezes e é isso que a gente acha
que pode estar causando a morte dos
neurônios e o mais legal é que a gente
não consegue só saber onde está errado
mas a gente consegue ver como vocês
podem observar que nessa imagem que eu
trouxe cada caixinha cada linha do meu
seqüenciamento da representada por um
pico as regiões com maiores picos são as
regiões que apresentaram mais linhas no
seqüenciamento mas nem significativas e
com a parte de cima primeira é o
camundongo saudável que o mundo mudou
como vocês podem ver a parte que tem a
caixinha que a informação saudável que a
gente quer
tem um pico bem grande ou seja está
sendo lida várias vezes porém a parte
que a linha que não tem informação
interessante ela não tá passando nada
porque você não tem quase nenhum pico
porém num camundongo com esclerose
lateral amiotrófica que é a parte de
baixo
vocês podem ver que a parte das
caixinhas continua sendo lida
porém a parte que tem a linha que a
informação que não deveria estar lá
passou a ser lida várias vezes inclusive
em um ponto mais do que a informação da
caixinha então isso aqui é um problema
muito grave para o corpo porque essa
informação que não era pra tá ali passou
a ser incluída e a grande sacada da
bioinformática é que ela não só permitiu
a gente vê isso aqui a ela de uma
informação pra gente não apenas de
quantidade ou de localização
mas ela deixou com que permitiu com que
a gente olhasse dentro do cérebro de um
camundongo e vendo o que estava
acontecendo lá dentro e aí agora a gente
pode pegar essa informação e levar de
volta pelo laboratório de biologia e
desenhar experimentos cada vez mais
precisos mais detalhados e que respondam
exatamente às perguntas que a gente quer
e é isso a conversa entre a biologia
computação que está permitindo cada vez
mais os campos de pesquisa avançarem e
se tornarem cada vez mais precisos e
eficientes
agradeço a vocês pela presença e espero
que vocês tenham gostado da palestra
qualquer coisa e meu contato daí fique à
vontade